[Music]
welcome to Pilate Amsterdam 2018 did you
have coffee did you enjoy the view great
there's a spot where the students can
get on the stage we're sort of an
academic can get on the stage where the
industry person get on the stage and the
open source to make and get on the stage
and just that sort of lovely chaotic mix
makes for a very joyful and interesting
conference at the same time I talked to
us about the gdpr and we talked about
the regulation and about some steps the
companies can take to assess their
readiness for it and also a background
and where it all came from general the
presentation was about the air app a web
and mobile app which displays air
pollution data from Macedonian polluted
usually 20 times over you limit during
winters and it's very very important to
get this data out there because with
some sort of data activism like this
we've been able to trigger 3,000 strong
movements of protesters three to gods
three days we had a workshop day where
there's sort of a longer talk and more
of a tutorial setting
talking about a larger open-source
project called rasa is focusing on
machine learning applied for dialogue
handling for message analytics to really
provide chat pods with the knowledge
they need to answer user queries oh my
god there was a Pokemon talk no okay I
did not go to the Pokemon talk so my day
was bad you set up a test for a data set
it's running everything's fine for like
two years and then out of nowhere it
starts failing and you're like why the
heck did I put this test here in the
first place like I can't remember why I
put this here
and so that struggle is a lot of what
sort of drove the development of marbles
[Music]
I talked about medical data science and
why it's really cool to work in that
field but also the challenge dispossess
so it's also sometimes kinda can suck
because things are slow and it's hard to
get data
[Music]
what made me come back not just the view
but also because I've been wanting to
speak here for a long time so it's
really exciting to actually be here and
speak but I'll be honest I mean I love
the city I love the venue I love the
food good talks nice people what's not
to come and this year to puffles the
damn best man perfect
[Music]